we had Barb's I want to see pure
happiness in his life and Wow Chrissy's
gonna have to fail to succeed this is
your bachelor season 24 to night live
double finale plus two breakups please'
halted production on The Bachelorette
recap grab your glasses it's time for
roses and Rosie and I'm leavin on a jet
plane
maybe not coronaviruses a real thing
we're all not okay but luckily we have
this big bottle of wine you guys I'm
Lauren Zima and we have so much to
discuss I thought I'd come back here
today and just talk to you about that
two night live finale shocking surprises
you need to become a real man Chris of
course I have my feelings
[Music]
okay yeah I've been holding on to this
brought out the Big Mama bottle so we
can talk about somebody else's mama
everybody you know what happened we had
a two night live finale that left us
shook it and then less than 48 hours
later Peter and Madison broke up that's
where we are I don't know where you guys
are watching this I hope at home safely
the coronavirus is no joke make sure
that you're taking care of yourselves
and each other and making smart
decisions and also you know make sure
you have wine but let's have a little
escapism this is a reality show after
all let's just talk about it and have
fun keep it chic put on high waisted I
said let's go let's start the day I put
on a beautiful basic shirt with a bit of
an interesting collar I said its classic
with a twist yeah let's get to it
so everybody we are gonna go back we're
gonna take a plane around the world and
back in time to last Monday night we
come back in Australia where Peters
going on one of the most
miserable-looking jobs I've ever seen
and that tracks for the vibes of this
doesn't it so we are back in the outback
in Australia where Peters family has
arrived this was Barb's old haircut
remember than your haircut she got on
the finale rhubarb came of a gleam and
glow up a new cut too and a colour
everybody what did you think let me know
in the comments below but anyway that
was the least of what we'd have to say
about barbed writer haircut but moving
on so barb
and Peter senior and little Jack are
here to see they're what we first saw
was Hannah and crying makes me so
emotional think about right off the bat
don't drink for every time somebody
cried this episode
this is like real for me to us
everything with Hannah and went well so
let's just fly through it
Hannah an was here and she was crying
because she was crying barb said why you
really remind me of me you and Peter
just like me and Peter senior I see you
and me we've been so happily married for
30 years a little younger look at our
two kids I want you to be my daughter
please bring her I'll get her bring her
Barbara said Oh a 747 a big one but this
is the quote best feeling a mother can
have it's the best feeling a mother can
have her feeling about Hannah Ann and
Peter says oh with these two women one
is easy Hannah and ones not medicine I
have one that's making it easier I mean
one is making it not so easy then
Madison arrives and Peter and she have a
chat and we would later find out from
barb at the second end of the live
finale that this chat was allegedly
three hours old on three hours for her
to come in and during this conversation
I saw both sides Madison was telling
Peter you put your feelings above mine
really just put your feelings and your
needs and your wants like way above mine
I made my feelings clear and you hurt my
feelings and Peter said matter how you
feel you're the only person that I truly
don't really know how you feel
he said of Madison quote I have zero
worries I have zero worries I do have to
raise a glass to my own at self because
Peter called it an ultimatum everybody
you don't want it to sound this way it's
kind of like an ultimatum
yeah there's no way for that not to come
off that way vindication out look now as
many of you have pointed out Peter did
say in an interview that I did with him
after the woman tell Evan you do not
think what Madison told him wasn't
ultimatum I don't feel like it was an
ultimatum I don't the fact he thought it
was just her setting your boundaries
well guess what now if you look back at
the timeline that I think that Peter was
probably trying to get Madison back at
that moment you know they were up and
down what was their relationship gonna
be so he is being very aware of what he
was saying on TV so I'm just speculating
that's my guess but anyway he said in
the episode then it was an ultimatum
I think I wish you wouldn't have said it
I'm glad that you did cuz it was on your
heart and that's important for me to
know and it was and he also said he was
glad that Madison gave it to him that's
what I was saying
you guys all tomatoes don't have to be
bad they're just clear
you know crystal clear way clearer than
this but this is why and I like that
it's not you know clear because it's an
alcoholic drink
I'm losing it right now I've talked
about ultimatum so many times at this
point this season that I think I've
borderline memorized the definition JC
can you put it on the screen
the final demand or statement of terms
the rejection of which will result in
the breakdown of negotiations now I also
want to raise a glass to Madison for
sanctuary who she wasn't being open and
honest she met Peters parents and she
said hey he slept with other people and
I didn't like it
you know our voice too Peter it would be
hard if you know he were to sleep with
someone else you know this family is so
open and talking about sex aren't they
for tax from the windmills to the walls
that Peter and Madison had put up
between the two of them not the walls
the fantasy suites they didn't go there
I noticed that they had some b-roll of a
windmill in this episode one final time
loved it but even though Peter had zero
worries zero worries his brother Jack
has some we want to raise a glass we
stand jack he straight up is like dude
you you do it you know obviously you're
very physical in relationships she
doesn't do it so this whole period of
not actually still having sex until
you're fully married that gonna be cool
who could cheers that and be fine that
that and Peter says I can compromise of
course I'm gonna be compromising part of
myself look you guys I'm not saying that
two different people can't be in a
successful relationship but I do think
that overall I was gonna throw things at
you tragedy illness difficulty so if you
and your partner on the same page about
your fundamental world views and the
glice goals that you have then I think
that overall it's gonna be easier and
have a higher chance of success that's
not what you had here and Jack knew the
window to the wall
till the sweat drop no mm-hmm Peters
nope
[Music]
um so Peter says that he can compromise
course I'm gonna be compromising part of
myself the relationships are about
compromise I think that relationships
are about working hard and compromising
in situations but they're not about
forgetting who you are what was the plan
you know
I'm clear and again we know where that
led to Chris he's gonna have to fail to
succeed
Marty waters okay again I'll do a Cheers
to Madison she says the truth she says
we're on different pages are kind of on
different pages like literally in every
way and Peter's response to that is to
say I want Madison more
oh and Barb's response is to say you
bring her home
and by her I mean very incredibly
specifically Hanna loves you were you
guys surprised the barb was ultimately
talking about Hanna Ann let me know in
the comments below
barb is crying or is she I don't know
it's kind of her to tell she's not there
for you and you saying that this is in
God's plan she's a dream come true God
has placed her there for you oh my gosh
that's big are you saying that Hannah
Hannah is an angel on earth that Hannah
an is an angel on earth hard and then
Peters like that mom you gotta stop
doing this doing this right now stop can
you just take a pause I have emotions
but are you have emotions how's it oh oh
oh that's Kelsey that's Victoria that
makes a lot of sense
people's emotions are running high in
these moments you know it's a big deal
your child has been gone and now they're
introducing you to potentially their
future wife so you want to make sure
that this is good this is forever
that's how we we got what we did get
she's gonna have to fail to succeed
which was a lot and also nothing it's
not gonna work you know luckily we have
these beautiful roses from Chris
Harrison's tropical Rose a Seagram's
escape launch party that have still
lasted
take the positive rate on roses and
Rosie
okay so Peter and Madison have a long
hug and they go and we know where they
both stand Peter's saying you're crazy
Madison was saying no and then they are
both standing in the desert with a bunch
of flies flying room and they drink some
apple juice got some parking hassles you
lady the Flies stick with wine everybody
don't drink if you don't want to drink I
don't care just be on the same page
about how you want to be social you kind
of mind nobody wants to be hanging out
with those flies maybe that's what I'm I
was like I gotta get out of here
getting flies don't drink for every fly
you see don't say from what I want to be
like I was willing to do whatever it
took to
bottom line Madison breaks up with Peter
and honestly his reaction wasn't quite
as emotional as I thought it would be
what did you guys think let me know in
the comments below
and now back in time to Tuesday so it's
part two of the live finale and we're
still back in Australia and we see that
Peter has gotten over Maddie real quick
he's feeling good I know what I have
with Hannah Hannah and that's true love
this is true love but then we find out
that the big reveal might be that Hannah
might not show up be honest I'm not
positive she's coming I don't know she's
questioning Peter said his heart was
torn I understand that like aunt Hannah
you want a guy who's into you but oh
that questioning didn't last long after
a quick commercial break aunt Anne was
in the car ready to go far right to her
future husband well or so she thought
maybe or did she I don't know she seemed
pretty surprised when Peter proposed to
her didn't she and after all Peter even
said Madison Madison why did he say that
that was wild wasn't it guys what was
going through your mind when Peter said
Madison we all thought that that was a
mix-up right
bottom line everybody Peter has stuck to
what he's wanted all season which is
that quote he just wants someone to love
him I want someone to love me just as
badly as I want them that's what he said
after getting engaged
and Peter owned it didn't he he said he
knew he did that matter so we gotta
raise a glass to Peter there are so many
things that I would do differently if I
could he is a paradise
[Music]
so Peter gets home and he's gotta tell
his family what happened and they answer
the door they're like the new sad Peter
see sad Lita as much as I thought we
would this finale it was more kind of
like just like a defeated look you know
like like we felt bad for him so much
was happening like Oh Peter Peter so
gosh you guys Barbra loves her son so
much and I want to raise a glass to that
at the end of the day do I think barb
could have handled things better yes
look don't we all just want to be loved
so barb Streep says we missed your
clothes mr.smile and peter senior says
even not a week it's been a week okay he
said then we're back in the studio on
Hannah Ana's backstage oh my god her
hair is longer whoo I like it it's
looking cute and barb is out there and
all night long we know we're gonna get
barb in the back it's Bob in a box
lounge
he's your Bobby too max she's got a face
for the world
Bobby the max I can't believe oh I just
know the word that's usually a bet song
and I can't believe that I changed it
out for that but it was it was begging
to happen had to happen
[Music]
[Music]
and then we're back in time again to an
undisclosed specific time of what Hannah
and Peter broke up you guys could you
tell right away that Hannah Anna and
Peter would be splitting when you saw
this moment that was seemingly from one
of their happy couple weekends
I'm asking you because I could you know
why because great couch I was taking
back to Ireland I can Beca cook friends
break up Greg couch everybody and he ran
seemed to know when she came in that
something was wrong right like she had
that sense and Peter starts crying he
tells her he's been struggling you know
and he says he can't give his whole
heart dirt I want so badly to be able to
give you everything give you my entire
heart which is very interesting because
just the night before we heard him say
that a hundred percent of his heart was
Hannah is that man forty seven ground
him all I've ever asked for this person
wanted to give me their whole heart and
her and delivered her first of what
would be several unbelievable speeches
of the night drink every time Hannah and
Slade with us breach where it's our
powerful Peter either you don't mean
what you say or you don't understand the
weight of your words
she tells Peter you took away my first
engagement you took away from me my
first engagement oh my god I liked so
much because like why did she say first
it was great every time these people get
a break up they gotta take a bathroom
break
okay did everyone use the restroom
everybody's good yeah you had a casual
breakup with your fiance in the restroom
everybody feeling okay everybody feeling
great about it you you're in the
bathroom you held up your ring and you
said you have done enough you've done
enough damage you got out of there
wonderful
Oh I also noted here quote barb is
clapping for her son getting dumped I'm
Chris Harrison told me she started that
applause so here again he's holding up
of that ring and as she is holding up of
that ring we are saying barb and Peter
senior in the box and she is saying torn
and conflicted Peter torn and conflicted
Peter all throughout this I stood by
your side and you can you took the most
precious moment I could ever imagine
because you selfishly did not want me to
walk away just did not want me to walk
away I need someone who's going to be I
just need someone who's gonna be true to
their words true to their words Oh
Hannah and 747 she crawled him out yes
we stand how I knew my way hey so
they're leaving and she does hold his
hand which is nice as she gets in the
car but then when she's in the car she
says Tom do the hands
but also Oh Oh was she calling back to
the Titanic thing you waited till the
very last moment to tell me that I was
the only girl left Pyrrha and then
confronts Peter and tells him that he
down blade the Madison thing downplayed
your feelings towards Madison Betty
blindsided her that's called being
blindsided Peter and that he reached out
to Anna be on the first red flag that
you gave to me was when you wanted to
reach out to Anna Brown to find closure
with her yes she reveals that during
their engagement Peter reached out to
Hanna B now I did as Chris Harrison for
his yes on why Peter would have done
that he says that he's probably just
giving her a heads up that he was
engaged neither they want to get back
together but whatever is a pretty
freakin wild reveal wasn't it
Hannah Ann says if she is strong and
she's been her own rock through this I
believe that we will see Hannah Ann on
the beaches of paradise what do you
think let me know in the comments below
and then back in time again we don't
know when but Chris went to see Madison
in Alabama and she finds out the Peters
single Peter is single and I do want to
say that I love that Madison asked is he
okay is he okay that was nice to me and
when she found out Peter was single
Madison smiled and as she was smiling he
could see barb in the box and barb was
doing this I'm shaking
his boxcar can time again Peter and
Madison meet up in LA and they haven't
seen each other since that moment but
they are here tonight
here's Madison so they both say that
they still love each other I love Peter
and how will this work Peter says and I
quote I think taking it one step at a
time one day at a time no taking like
one step at a time
oh you know no that would be less than
two days he is the smartest way to go do
we have a million obstacles yeah do we
have a million and one obstacles yeah
is it all uphill probably probably
that's what Peter says and I thought
barb was gonna come a little upset but
pretty chill I thought she'd say
something like look Hanahan showed my
son more love that day but we've since
come to realize that he loves Madison
and so we're gonna work through this I
know no barb is a woman who doesn't
waste a word she said quote he's gonna
have to fail to succeed he's gonna have
to fail to succeed she said quote his
friends and family don't think it's
gonna work and all his friends all his
family everyone that knows him knows
that it's it's not you know it's not
gonna work although she did waste some
words on repeating how many hours
Madison kept her waiting don't have
three drinks for every three hours that
barb says because she had us wait three
hours for her to come in so we were
there three hours we had just come
across the country and we had to wait
three hours and when she did come in
yeah that is so heavy dad what's your
take on this she even told her eyes with
something to say in Spanish I think
Bianca might be like you know me we all
quickly went to Google Translate or of
your Spanish speakers you just thought
about it but it was kind of hard to hear
what you say in the translation of what
she ultimately said is a little bit up
in the air but bottom line
barb we could hear you I am telling you
that I love Madison so here's like mom
please I love her
we had both pita and bad barb and sad
everybody well so you know let's bring
out Claire ladies and gentlemen and I'm
thinking is gonna take a turn for the
better you know now we're gonna talk
about the Bachelorette and think is
gonna be really good and we're gonna
move forward to the new season and now
we know it's been at least temporarily
halted in production due to coronavirus
guys less than 48 hours after that
bachelor finale we found out via
Instagram that Peter and Madison had
decided mutually to not pursue their
relationship they both commented
positive things on each other's
Instagram announcements about their
breakup and then barb took to Instagram
and posted a video of herself and some
friends singing and dancing - leaving on
a jet plane
on a jet plane don't know when I'll be
back again I don't know what the fat
means I don't know if it means that she
was talking about her son's relationship
being gone or if she was just dancin and
prancin and you know on one but bottom
line Peter and barber hanging out again
Madison's doing her thing
and Claire unfortunately is that a
standstill so what is life what do we
take from all this I think at the end of
the day we take that this season was
wild
it was wonderful television that we were
all wrapped up in and that created
discussions commentary the exchange of
opinions and hopefully growth from
everybody who watched and interacted
with the content and what I take away
from it is that this shows the gift that
keeps on giving
it's reality show that I really enjoy
watching and drinking along with and
importantly it brings us all together I
hope for it a safe distance because of
coronavirus but mentally and emotionally
we're here with each other I love you
guys so much thank you thank you for
watching I appreciate you and all my
love - Peter - Madison - Hannah
- barb this was unforgettable and iconic
I love you so much
thank you for watching cheers babes my
leaving on a jet plane don't know when
we'll be back again yes we do we'll be
back really soon we love you guys bye
[Music]
you